their country is at war
but for the many ukrainian soldiers the
fight is personal
i told my wife to grab the children and
to hide in the basement and i went to
the drafting station and joined my unit
straight away and the next day from the
army base we moved to the front line
my wife and children were under
occupation for two weeks but then they
managed to escape through a humanitarian
corridor
andrei is from the city of buchar it's
25 kilometers northwest of kiev in the
path of russian invaders
and his unit has come under heavy
bombardment since the start of the war
overnight on thursday a missile hit an
oil depot near kiev used to supply
ukraine's armed forces in the center of
the country
killing and injuring people waiting for
help
the city remains under curfew
mario paul's city council announced on
friday an airstrike on a theater on
march 16th
may have killed 300 people
the building was being used to shelter
women and children and was clearly
marked for pilots to see 130 people were
rescued but as many as 1 300
are believed to still be inside
the death toll is expected to go up
the defense ministry says ukraine's
armed forces have stopped the russian
advance and are taking back territory
near the capital
but those forces are spread thin across
several fronts
leaving some ukrainians on their own
oh you
oh a strong bombardment of our village
began yesterday at nine o'clock hail
stones and rockets the house burned down
[Music]
there were a lot of tanks we passed a
lot of tanks and a lot of soldiers
especially the enemy for some reason
there were fewer of our soldiers
we also saw armored personnel carriers
and dad found a rubber bullet somewhere
salvaging what they can moving on
staying strong
we will fight till the end as best we
can some with weapons and some will help
with moral support and by transferring
funds to our army
our guys should have everything helmets
and body armor humanitarian corridors do
seem to be working when they hold the
government of ukraine has been able to
move thousands of people to safety but
it also accuses russia's government of
forcibly relocating more than four
hundred thousand ukrainian citizens to
russian-held territory now russia says
that they went willingly ukraine says
they are hostages
zain basravi al-jazeera level